John Mayer who's your body he is my body
you've gone to Grateful Dead shows with
him with on road trip from uh LA to San
Francisco to see the day and on the way
you said a gay bar and you took him to a
gay bar and you said he was a good
wingman I took him to a gay bar in San
Francisco when we got there was the day
that marriage equality happened I say
and it happened to be gay pride in San
Francisco and I said to him listen I'm
going out tonight because this is the
night and he said oh man I want to come
with you like that'll be great not okay
we had a bowl and you say it was good
wingman why because people come over to
say hi to John Mayer and then you're
sitting there and then you know and it
was kind of what blow these guys are
yeah yeah yeah well I just blew John's
fans any of John's fans came up and you
blew them yes it was really great yes /
no Tracy why was he a great wingman well
I mean you know look he was additive for
me to go out with right it's great he's
big listen he would have been additive
if he wasn't John Mayer cuz he's big and
tall and handsome it's always good to go
out with another you know another guy
who people are gonna want to be around